just want to follow up on the last video
where we threw balls in the air and saw
how long they stayed up in the air we
use that to figure out how fast we
initially threw the ball and how high
they went in the air and the last video
we did it with specific numbers in this
video I just want to see if we can
derive some interesting formulas so we
can do the computations really fast in
our brains while we're playing this game
out on some type of a field and we don't
necessarily have have any paper around
so let's say that the ball is in the air
for a delta T delta T is equal to time
in the air time in the air then we know
that the time up is going to be half
that which is the same thing as the time
down the time up is going to be equal to
delta T do that same color is going to
be equal to the time in the air divided
by two so how what was our initial
velocity well all we have to do is
remind ourselves that the change in
velocity the change in velocity which is
the same thing as the final velocity
minus the initial velocity so the final
velocity remember we're just talking
about half of the path of this ball so
the time that it gets released and it
goes as going as kind of its maximum
upward velocity and go slower and slower
slower all the way until it's stationary
for just a moment and then starts going
down again remember the acceleration is
constant downwards this entire time so
what is the final velocity if we just
consider half of the time well it's the
time it's zero so it's going to be zero
minus our initial velocity minus our
initial velocity when it was taking off
that's our change in velocity this is
our change in velocity this is our
change in velocity is going to be equal
to the acceleration of gravity the
acceleration of gravity not negative 9.8
meters per second squared or the
acceleration due to gravity when an
object is in free fall to be technically
correct x times the time that we are
going up so times delta T up which is
the same thing I won't even write it
delta T up is the same thing as our
total time in the air our total time in
the air divided by two
and so we get we get negative the
initial velocity is equal to this thing
when you divided by two is going to be
four point nine meters per second
squared we still have our negative out
front times our delta T times our delta
T you remember this is our total time in
the air not just the time up this is our
total time in the air and then we
multiply both sides times a negative we
get our initial velocity is just going
to be equal to four point nine four
point nine meters per second squared
times the total time the total time that
we are in the air or you could say that
or you could say it's the it's going to
be nine point eight meters per second
squared times half of the time that
we're in the air either of those would
get you the same calculation so let's
figure out our total distance or the
distance that we travel in that first in
the time up so that will give us our
peak distance remember that distance or
I should say displacement in this
situation displacement is equal to
average velocity average velocity times
change in time the change in time that
we care about is the time up so that is
our delta T over two our total time our
total time divided by two this is our
this is our time up time up and what's
our average velocity well the average
velocity if we assume constant
acceleration is your initial velocity
plus your final velocity over to it's
really just the mean of the two things
well we know what our initial velocity
is our initial velocity is this thing
over here so this is this thing over
here our final velocity remember we're
just talking about the first half of the
time the balls in the air so our it's
final velocity is zero we're talking
when it gets to this this peak point
right over here that's from two videos
ago that peak point right over there so
our average velocity is just going to be
our average velocity is just going to be
this stuff divided by two so it's going
to be four point nine meters per second
squared
times delta T times delta T over over -
so this right here this is our average
velocity velocity average so let's stick
that back over here so our maximum
displacement our maximum displacement is
going to be our average velocity so that
is 4.9 m/s squared times delta T times
delta T all of that over 2 and then we
multiply it again times the total times
the time up so times delta T over 2
again this is the same thing these are
the same thing and then we can simplify
it our maximum displacement is equal to
four point nine meters per second
squared times delta T squared times
delta T squared all of that over all of
that over four and then we can just
divide 4.9 divided by four 4.9 divided
by four is was it it's one point one
point two one point two two five I think
let me just get the calculator out I
want to do that in my head get this far
make a careless mistake 4.9 divided by 4
is 1 point two two five so this is so
our maximum displacement is going to be
one point two two five times our total
time in the air total time in the air
squared which is pretty which is a
pretty straightforward which is a pretty
straightforward calculation so this is
this is our max displacement kind of how
far do we how high are we get displaced
right when right when that ball is
stationary or is has no net velocity
just for a moment it starts decelerating
downwards so we can use that if a ball
is in the air for five seconds we can
verify our computation from the last
video it our maximum displacement 1.2 -
5 times 5 squared which is 25 will give
us 30 point 6 - 5 that's what we got in
the last video if the ball is in the air
for I don't know two point three seconds
so it's one point two to five times two
point three squared then that means it
went six point four eight meters in the
air so anyway I just wanted to give you
a a simple expression that gives you
that gives you the maximum displacement
from the ground
assuming air resistance is negligible as
a function of the total time in the air
and I don't know I find that pretty
pretty fun and it's a it's a neat game
to play